my name is Zachary Palmer I am a junior
here at the college majoring in history
minoring in politics and classical
education and I am a Winston Churchill
fellow Larry P Arnn is the 12th
president of Hillsdale College he
received his BA from Arkansas State
University and his MA and PhD in
government from the Claremont Graduate
School he also studied at Worcester
College Oxford University where he
served as director of research for the
late Sir Martin Gilbert the official
biographer of Winston Churchill from
1985 to 2000 he served as president of
the Claremont Institute for the Study of
statesmanship and political philosophy
he serves on several boards of directors
and he previously served on the US Army
War College Board of Visitors for two
years for which he earned the Department
of the Army's outstanding civilian
service medal in 2015 he received the
Bradley prize from the Lynde and Harry
Bradley Foundation a member of numerous
organizations including the Churchill
Center he is the author of three books
Liberty and learning the evolution of
American education
the founders key the divine and natural
connection between the Declaration and
the Constitution and what we risk by
losing it
and most recently Churchill's trial
Winston Churchill and the salvation of
free government ladies and gentlemen
please help me in welcoming dr. Arne
[Applause]
Thank You Zack
good evening have we enjoyed our CCA
what are we happy to get a chance today
to look at Winston Churchill's but just
that doesn't happen every day does it
Doug Jeffrey actually asked me do you
think that was a body double and I said
you know Doug there are three butts that
I've never seen and one of them is
Winston Churchill on when I'm his Albert
Finney's and the other is whoever that
double might have been okay I can't
believe I said that so you know the
college has a big commitment to Winston
Churchill and that's because he's great
but I need to explain that because this
is a college and so we're supposed to
explain what we do and so I'm gonna
answer a few questions about it I'm
gonna ask them of myself and then later
you can ask them what has the study of
statesmanship to do with liberal
education that's the first one do you
know what Liberty liberal education is
like Zack here he's undertaking liberal
education and he just introduced me and
I'm significant around here and he was
serious about it right he never did that
before
everything he's doing in his life he
never did before
every big thing and what does he need to
study he doesn't know what he's gonna do
with his life he actually only needs to
study things that last forever he needs
to get oriented about those liberal
education is about those today with some
freshmen at lunch
karley here the freshmen know too bad
she effectively accused me of blasphemy
today and because her point was we teach
we treat the Greeks as important as the
Bible and I said so I'm guilty of
blasphemy now she loves the college all
of them did they were all freshmen it's
easy to pick on them and and there was a
young man here who's the applicant you
know and he's dying to get in and he's
the friend of a member of our presidents
Club and so we're all there for this
like really tense and significant lunch
so I got him with a bunch of freshmen
and we had a free-for-all and I said
okay Carly you mean blasphemy and she
said no I don't I said yes you do and
she said and I said I accuse you of
ignorance let's talk that through well
you know by the end 45 minutes it was a
sacred experience everything about it
was I was explaining to her what you can
know about God just by thinking about it
and I showed her that and she'd been
raised by very decent people and you
know she's here she came from California
she can go to college anywhere she wants
to if she got in here she came here to
the cold in part because she thinks will
teach her how to be and I tried to help
today mostly I tried to have an amusing
time because it's easy around here
and at the end I said so you see you
could know these things about God you
know what you can know about God by
reason according to Thomas Aquinas you
could know that he can't move you could
know that he must be immaterial you can
know that he must be eternal and he has
to be those things you you can know that
he can't change I'll just give you one
example if you change then that means
one of three things it means improvement
or decay or chain
changing for no reason and all the three
three of those things are imperfections
we change we're not God that's what we
do here
what's politics Ling politics changes
politics is urgent politics is so often
ugly why would you do that here and I'll
answer that question quickly I haven't
got to Winston Churchill yet you don't
discover the need to know the big things
by thinking about them first you just
cover them by choosing what to do
that young woman chose to come here
she's good choice I mean because of her
mostly but we're pretty good too and
that's a question about the good what
should I do
we're just isn't as sensitive as dogs we
got to sleep every day we get hungry we
got to make a living but there's
something else going on every time we
choose and that thing is what's the
right thing to do and this right thing
to do even if we corrupt the idea even
if we just style everything right just
because we happen to want it the
question of right comes up and that
question looks at reaches up to god
here's another reason why we study that
Winston Churchill said of Adolf Hitler
Winston Churchill do you know was a very
great man
it said breathtaking
he had flaws all that right but nobody
liked him he writes of Hitler
you see these dictators on their
pedestals surrounded by the bayonets of
their soldiers and the trench ins of
their police on all sides they are
guarded by masses of armed men and
cannons and airplanes and forts and they
want themselves before the world yet in
their hearts there is unspoken fear they
are afraid of words words spoken abroad
thought stirring at home all the more
powerful because forbidden these terrify
them a little mouse of thought appears
in the room and even the mightiest
potentates are thrown into a panic a
tyrant is the enemy of learning any high
thing that's the worst thing about them
and Winston Churchill knew that didn't
go to college I met Sir Martin Gilbert
through him I met
Penelope Arne in a little library in
North London called the veena library
and now this library is we we were to
meet there and then I was to walk with
him to the London School of Economics
where I was supposed to be a student
although I hardly ever went there I
moved to Oxford right away because he
gave me a job and I had to chase him
down the stairs and say where should I
live
and he said Oxford I said ok so I moved
over the weekend but because of him I
met Penelope my wife right that's a big
day for me
but I walk in this library and it's this
quiet little library and there are these
two Jewish ladies running it older
ladies and I'm
Shai and from Arkansas you know and
never been abroad before and I said I'm
looking for Martin Gilbert and they knew
immediately who that was
and they walked me over and he's looking
at a book it's a primary school reader
and it's got the kind of primary colors
in it and then he said hello nice to
meet you
look at this book you know what it was
it was a textbook from Hitler's Germany
and the story in the textbook is a
little storybook pictures and turned the
page and a few words on each page and
what was happening was some German
children with blond hair and blue eyes
and brown uniforms and backpacks went
into a butcher shop and the butcher was
a jewish book butcher he actually looked
rather like Bluto in the Popeye cartoons
and the plot of the story is that he was
tempting these German children into the
back and he was butchering them primary
school little kids and Martin Gilbert
said notice this and he pointed because
there are sides of pork hanging
everywhere and and he says notice that
the color the hue of the sides of pork
is the same as the hue of the skin of
the butcher and nobody else is like that
that's education under a tyrant
you know what Churchill said education
is he didn't go to college today if you
hear a politician Republican or Democrat
describe education it's a little bitter
recently but if he hears him to describe
it they never know what it is right
they think it's success they think it's
you know where as what Zach needs to
know and what Carly needs to know is
they need to know how to be they need to
know how to live their lives because
their whole lives are in front of them
and everything turns on how they choose
and we don't know that today see
and that means that we're going down the
road where you find Hitler at the end
right in 1946 the war's over Churchill
has become the greatest man in the world
and he goes to the University of Miami
and gets an honorary degree he always
made the same joke when he got one I've
been so much better at receiving degrees
than I was at taking exams but I'll read
you what he won what he wrote this is an
age of machinery and specialization
I hope nonetheless or all the more that
the purely vocational aspect of
university study will not be allowed to
dominate or monopolize the attention of
the returning servicemen soldiers coming
back from war in in 1953 Ivan I've known
this for about a year and you know I'm
old now and I've been studying Winston
Churchill for a long time in 1953 he's
the Prime Minister of the country for
the second time and they're having a
fight because they're starting adult
education and he won't let them bring
the bill forth the Secretary of
Education doesn't understand what
education is about she wants it all to
be vocational just training for a job do
you see how ungenerous that is because
all you're going to teach him to do is
to do what you teach him to do instead
of teaching him to be human helping them
to learn to be fully human right and so
he says he have to only paraphrase this
I don't have a quote right here but he
says for adult people to address
themselves to the greatest books in
their age what a satisfaction I was a
late starter myself he says you see
he thinks human beings are ins not means
that's why he saw Hitler for what he was
he goes on engines were made for men not
men for engines it ought to be part of
our religion to see that our country is
well governed well governed means by the
way an education system and a governing
system that treats you is the point of
it all the purpose expert knowledge
however indispensable is no substitute
for a generous and comprehending outlook
upon the human story with all its
sadness and all its unquenchable hope
what does that mean that means that the
stakes in politics are everything and
you can only play for the stakes in the
right way if you understand that
politics is not everything in the great
statesmen who save everything are the
ones who know that
why should we study Churchill you see
what we should study statesman our
mental weather is mostly taken up with
not figuring out what you can know about
God my reason as opposed to faith that's
a really wonderful thing to know there's
a book you should read it I happen to be
I read it when I was in graduate school
and I'm reading it again right now and
it's a perfect book for night time
because each chapter is short and it's
complicated but it's great it's called
the similar country Gentiles by Thomas
Aquinas and I read it forever ago I was
told by my great teacher I was trying to
study the ethics which I teach now and
he said I wasn't get in and he said go
home and read the Summa contra Gentiles
and come back when you have so I'm
reading it again right and it starts
with saying the first book there four
books independent books and they're all
the first ones about God
what's God like right well that's a
glorious thing to do and you can't do it
if you're me for a long time because
then you get sleeping you got a sleeper
you'll die right but mostly you don't do
that mostly what you do is figure out
what to do make decisions and make them
right and the Faculty of doing that is
called practical wisdom or prudence and
Aristotle says in book 1 book 6 of the
ethics but if you want to get good at
that study the people who have the
reputation for being good at it
especially statesmen and Winston
Churchill lives leaves the Richards
richest record of any statesman 50 books
read them I envy you the chance to read
them for the first time
and then he was in the most significant
events in human history alas we live in
an age where those are so recent because
we live in a very troubled time
something that Churchill knew why war
why statesmanship why Churchill why war
you know there are conflicts among
people and they're bound to be and
that's because they're not angels
they're going to be conflicts among
nations and the reason they're going to
be many nations is because we don't all
speak the same language and politics
arises from the gift of human speech
which is also the gift Bible whereby we
figure out what to do if we figure out
well and so we're gonna be organized in
these communities and you know they're
going to gather force and they're gonna
build harmony if they're successful and
that makes them very fierce and warm and
so there's going to be Wars and so then
how do you win them you know that thing
I said about Churchill that his
greatness was understanding that
politics was not everything his
greatness at war involved understanding
that war was not everything and that
changed how he fought it I'm gonna
explain that it's really awesome how he
did that I mean and then you know he
wrote books about it so you can
understand
he didn't like war he was really good at
it you know he fought in first time he
fought was in Afghanistan he walks up
and down up right behind the rocks it's
a it's a war fought just like the Afghan
war today it's fought up in the rocks by
the hills and so he'd walk up and down
so they could shoot at him and then
people stopped and so they would write
about him writing back the reports and
the dispatches they call it about the
battles and so they got used to that so
they didn't mention his name anymore so
he bought a horse and rode that up and
down and then the next place he fights
is in the sedan well he went to Cuba too
but that was a kind of spy trip that
pretended to be something else but he
goes to this to the sedan and he's in a
cavalry charge last big one they ever
had the British and people talk about
him about what he was like on a
battlefield then the biggest thing the
best thing was he went to South Africa
and they'd made a rule that you couldn't
write articles for the press if you were
a serving officer and they made that
rule for him because he was the most
famous commentator on all of the wars he
was in and became a public figure
including talking bad about the generals
and he was a second lieutenant see and
so they made a rule that he couldn't do
it and so what he would do then is he
would resign his commission and serve
and and write articles for a while and
then he'd joined back up and serve some
more and at the moment he gets on this
armoured train and he knows it's a bad
idea he'd been on the dang thing before
if you think about it for a minute an
armored train is a stupid idea because
they're very heavily armored and stuff
but you know exactly where they're going
and they gotta have the tracks and so he
said well I don't know and this guy halt
dein says please come with me I want you
to come so he gets on the dang train and
it's attacked and
derailed and he's the journalist right
and they're all cowering and there's
hills on both sides and rocks and people
behind it and their small arms fire and
artillery fire there were 13 killed and
everybody sent a panic and so he gets
out and he walks the circle out in the
open around the locomotive you know
investigating bullets coming down you
know and he doesn't notice them God did
not make such a forces I merely to stop
a bullet
Churchill was confident and so he comes
and opens the door and he says wait we
can get this thing going and then they
worked for an hour he's the one that
works out in the open and they get the
train going right and then you know what
he says when it's over he says call bang
he's eventually captured by the way it
could have got away but he didn't want
to leave the other guys behind and and
of course he escapes by the way and
becomes a national hero and gets like
the department but on the scene he says
to captain halt dein he says thank you
for letting me do that in that weird you
know
he said the whole Derbyshire light
infantry has seen that and now I'm going
to be elected to Parliament in he was a
fighter in the Second World War
he's that one of two people that I've
ever read about who was dashing in the
trenches Duncan Duncan was Arcos the
other one he wore a white sash and had a
baton and it pipe and he would charge
you know with his baton and his pipe and
his white sash Churchill would go
exploring with his troops in the
trenches at night and it would go like
this they'd be there's a really great
memory of it written by one of his
senior officers and he'd be looking out
over there and you know he'd look around
just like a little boy and say let's go
out there and then they'd go crawl
around
and get up close to the Germans and hear
him write his spirit rose in the face of
war but he hated it too he then he's a
politician and then a big war comes the
First World War
and you know people mistrusted Winston
Churchill and one of the reasons is they
trusted him to tell the truth and he was
very ambitious and very quick and that
meant that they were always afraid that
no matter what he get his mitts on he
was going to take it over and that's
because he did all the time Javed
Neville Chamberlain crazy with that he
just couldn't be stopped but at the
beginning of both world wars one of them
Herbert Asquith is the Prime Minister
and the other Neville Chamberlain is the
Prime Minister within three months of
the war broken out they made him the
chairman of the committee to coordinate
the hold war because he had energy and
he knew what to do
Jon Kovel one of the best witnesses for
Churchill was a Chamberlain guy in the
Prime Minister's office when Churchill
took Chamberlain's place in May of 1940
and he kept a diary it was illegal
Martin Gilbert found a document that we
were soon to publish and the document
said they would do spoofs on each other
the people working for Churchill and
just make each other miserable and one
of the spoofs was a pretended memo from
Churchill saying it's my understanding
that you've been keeping a diary this is
a violation of the Official Secrets Act
and they give it to him you know they're
all named John John Peck Eric seals and
Eric and Colville and the others give it
to him and he just sits there and he's
just a hangdog and their idea is they're
gonna let him go home and suffer and
then come back the next day and tell him
but they can't bear it he's so
devastated
right but he kept keeping his diary and
it's good that he did because here's
what he thought there Chamberlain people
he's steady Churchill is a wild man this
is gonna be terrible and then two weeks
later he's reading oh this is how you
fight a war George was a good at it
he loved it and he hated it he made
these points about for the first one is
it isn't the point you don't fight in
order to fight if you think that you're
Hitler do you know the Spartans didn't
think that and they were warlike really
the Romans didn't think that only crazy
people think that and once in a while
small souls who just only know how to do
that Churchill was always clear that's
not what we do we do that in order to do
what we do and then that brings up the
second thing I'll tell you I invite you
to have the experience of reading this
because it's just you know people people
will say to me sometimes you know
because I happen to know a lot of
politicians and I've known some good
ones few and they'll say to me you know
who's our next Churchill and I always
say well God will figure that out when
he wants to because they won't and it
won't be for a while and they'll say do
you think so-and-so is like Winston
Churchill and I'll say yeah he's very
like him you know fought in five Wars
commanded in the two greatest wars in
history wrote 50 books won the Nobel
Prize for Literature he's just like him
[Laughter]
George Bush and Ronald Reagan I was
asked that by Reagan's
closer I think but
so this thing that he's good at and the
thing I'm telling you when the war's
broke out he every time a big one work
out he had foreseen it and he'd spent at
least a decade trying to stop it and
failed and then he thought okay now
we're gonna fight let's show him what
that's like
see and it's just like in the army by
the way I was on the board of the Army
War College Zack mentioned it and what
do you learn at the Army War College
there's rank and then there's people who
fought and that cuts across rank because
war is very urgent and you tend to pay
more attention to talent in such a
situation and so trishal gets promoted
they don't like him
well they came to love him he became the
greatest man in the world very late in
his life
it happened in 1940 because he just did
amazing things I'll describe one of them
but he's he's good right but he thinks
so here the second thing something's
changing in the world we live in the
most dangerous age in human history
right now we live longer we're less
likely to be killed much more likely to
be killed ten million at a time and it's
happened more than once we live in the
age in which slaughterhouses are built
and whole communications are devised and
incineration systems are devised to
dispose of human beings in ways that
you'd hardly do to count where'd that
come from
and what does it mean for war in 1898
Churchill is on a battlefield in the
Sudan and he sees a charge and I think
this is the earliest instance I can see
of it
I actually need to find this as you can
see I'm not paying any attention to my
notes so I'm lost I can't find it so
I'll describe it so in the in the river
war one of his very best books in an
early book and in the chapter called the
Battle of Omdurman on Germans down on
the Nile and really the first one of the
first for sure Islamic Republic's had
taken the city of Khartoum which is a
thousand miles down the Nile from
Alexandria where the mouth is up in the
Mediterranean and this body of Allah was
just title he took the city and he
publicly beheaded a man named Gordon
general Gordon a figure of the empire
and a heroic man and they sent evidence
of it to London and they said we got to
go get him so they sent a camel core and
it got chopped to pieces the Nile is
impassable for much of its length and so
they couldn't go by boat and so then
they employed an an engineering kind of
general and Kitchener with whom
Churchill had many dealings much of them
unhappy and Kitchener you know figured
out how to do it they put a whole bunch
of stuff on boats and they floated him
down to the place where the light now it
was impassable and then they took the
stuff off and what it was was a railway
and they built a railway around the
shallow parts back to the deep part then
they put all the boats and all the trips
echad troops and all the equipment on
the boats and locomotives on the trains
and they took them down to the place
then they put it all back on the boats
and now they've got a major army with
good point gunboats outside Khartoum and
35,000 dervishes charge and
the one that got the farthest got within
a hundred yards and it was a football
field 150 yards a football field and a
half they could hardly see the British
lines Churchill describes this and you
know what Churchill thinks he's doing
because you know that story about what
he said to halt dein he said I've won
glory I'm gonna get elected to
Parliament and it would be vain glory
except he risked his life to get it he
was serious about it right but here and
see this is this is the vengeance
against the beheading of Gordon it's an
extremely popular war and the British
didn't lose 30 people and they killed
20% of the dervishes and Churchill is
horrified when he writes about it I am
just describe it it's in that chapter
you'll find it
he says the white flags that's the
frontline troops carrying big white
flags of the Derby's just come over the
hill they have no sense of the impending
tragedy of all of the of the varieties
of arms they had they were most inferior
in artillery and so they opened with
that and then they began to be
slaughtered and he describes it it's
it's beautiful it's it's terrible and
beautiful he describes the bullet
shearing through muscle and bone and the
sand and the sweat and the blood and the
screaming and then he moves to the next
paragraph and he says the infantry back
at the British lines fired steadily and
stolid Lee in rough paraphrase although
they were interested in the work it
became tedious but they noticed that
after each looked down the sights that
were fewer targets than the one before
then they say that soon the barrels
began to to melt and they had to bring
water jackets and keep changing them and
they had to bring more
he's describing ammunition he's
describing a factory there's a factory
for killing and he never calls the
British brave he calls the dervishes and
you know Churchill didn't like these
dervishes didn't like that kind of
people he didn't like despotic religion
and he denounced it hard in this book
but at the time of the battle only they
are brave and then he reflects to
himself he says used to be bravery was
the chief asset in war is it machinery
now that's a heck of a reflection for
somebody 26 years old and then he
developed that for the rest of his life
right cinnamon as they called shall we
all commit suicide mankind has never
been in this position before without
having approved appreciably in virtue or
enjoying wider wiser guidance he's got
into his hands at last the means of his
own destruction death stands waiting at
attention silent and expected waiting
for a word from the frail being so long
his servant now for once his master he's
afraid of war afraid of all will do in
1936 and what good's a constitution
he writes that we free countries we
can't afford to be perpetually at war
have you noticed that in the news lately
when we get into a war we always go
courting Winston Churchill we don't
quote what he actually wrote because
what he wrote was if you're forever at
war then that disturbs the liberal
society the liberal society is where we
get to be important just ordinary people
right but if everything is conscripted
as it must be he says the way war is
going then there will be no room for any
of us to be freedom and that would be
free and that means that's got to be
stopped
you gotta find a way to win that and
when fast and not fight if you can help
it
he was always did you know in 1954
wednesday churchill refused dwight
eisenhower to go to vietnam with him and
eisenhower then did a remarkable thing
that that that that two years later it
actually amounted to the destruction of
the power the public demonstration of
the destruction of the power of britain
because in 1956 the British and the
Israelis and the French attacked the
Egyptians at Suez and the United States
made him stop
but in 1954 and marette fir'd the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
said to Churchill he said we can help
you in Egypt and Churchill turned him
down he said you're gonna go and spend
the best you've got against proxies for
which they care nothing why is that good
strategy
so when I'm describing here is an entire
life of a man who's a fighter and is
good at it and loves it and tries to
stop it on the argument that we must
spare ourselves so we can live like free
people and when he sees Hitler coming
you see why he understood him
he understood did if you read about the
score the point system that they got in
China now and they're watching what you
read because they're afraid for the same
reason so you know him for what he was
and so he urgently sets about the job
getting the country to rearm because
we're in a position to stop him without
a fight and we've got to do that and
then they won't do that and they lie
cheat and steal you know in the most
honorable way and they pretend to be
rebuilding and they don't first they
won't admit that they're going to try
then they claim they're going to try and
they half try then they get serious
about it but it's late now and so then
and remember this we can only see
Churchill after he became the greatest
man in the world and did the greatest
things he did but of course most of his
life is not like that most of his life
is him being the most reluctant guy to
call on his people to sacrifice their
way of life
but then 1940 comes and in some kind of
poetic and ironic cosmic justice he's
the one picked to fight the war you seen
the movie darkest hour you can't
understand what's great about that
seeing that event that it describes
until you understand how reluctant he
was to do that kind of thing but now
the Germans have beaten the French and
the Germans are in alliance with the
Russians and we are distant and so then
of course as the France is collapsing
and he's flying back and forth begging
the French to stay in the war and you
know he's picked Prime Minister because
that's a piece of hard medicine and at
last they're ready to take it and so he
goes over there and he begs them and
they quit anyway having a treaty not to
do it and so he destroys their fleet in
the port of Iran Iran in North Africa
and he won't send him any more airplanes
and then France Falls anyway and so then
Edward Halifax Edward wood Lord Halifax
is the Foreign Minister and he's the
chief of the appeasers along with
Chamberlain and he brings a proposal
conveyed through Mussolini Hitler's
henchmen not yet in the war and says we
want to talk peace we'll be really
generous and I want you to see this is a
dramatic demonstration of what life
demands of us and we'll never know until
heaven whether we were right or not I'll
explain why because this guy who's the
one who's trying to stop this war from
happening he's the only one who doesn't
want to open a peace conference and the
reason is it'll be in the papers and
then the whole war effort of Britain
pitiful thing that it is will collapse
and he's the Prime Minister but they
don't vote in the cabinet they're not
voting over there today when the whole
place thing is collapsing they have a
discussion and the Prime Minister has
the authority to summarise what they've
decided and if you don't like it you
quit and so if he says we're gonna fight
on and Halifax says I quit the
government Falls he doesn't have the
power and so he had to do something more
questionable
then vote he had to talk him into it
it's amazing that he did he talks for an
hour he didn't have time to write the
speech out which is very uncommon to
people took notes and we have the notes
and we know what he said he described
the war situation in blank terms we're
gonna be up against overwhelming odds
there's gonna be an avid naval battle
remember we still have a Navy but that
will go the way of an air battle and
they have more airplanes but they have
to fight over here on our side we don't
know how that's gonna go but there's
good hope and then you know if they land
the towns they're gonna take first have
names like names in New England and the
Americans will come and help us that's
the hope remember we are the hope the
only thing big enough and you got to
understand about Churchill but at this
point he's familiar with the workings of
the great world war like no one else
he's as familiar with that as I am
familiar with the operations of this
College and that's infinitely larger
right but he can just think about it and
see it and he can see gonna need us I'm
gonna have to talk him into coming but
meanwhile I got a hold on right and he
closes the speech with this and I'm
asking to remember the last person to
say this he says I've been thinking in
these last few days I'll interrupt and
say that two weeks after this he's told
the plans for resisting an invasion if
they get us sure and he records we don't
have the speech but we record that he
said that he wrote he records that he
wrote a speech about what if the Germans
land because he'd been informed they're
going to take southern England and that
means including London and the speech
was entitled you can take one with you
that's like the Spartans except for a
whole country it's to my wife's mother
and father my wife was born after that
which means he had to come home no wife
no children so what testing he says that
I've been thinking in these last few
days whether it is part of my duty to
open negotiations with that man and I
believe that if I were for a moment to
consider parley or surrender every one
of you would rise up and tear me down
from my place
if this island story is to end at last
let it end when each of us lies choking
in his own blood
he talked him into that they leapt up
and patted him on the back and for the
rest of his life friend and enemy still
had the same friends and enemies they
treated him like the greatest man in the
world and my point is you can't be sure
that was the right thing cuz you know
what Britain lost there's a lot of after
given guessers John Charlie an excellent
historian right he writes a book that's
what caught cost Britain it's great
greatness that's a factual point and
Churchill himself had made the case a
million times we can't do that and it's
not like he just said I'm the Prime
Minister you got to do it he had to
summon from himself a speech that
there's no living person he's
responsible for that then of course he
watched it collapse and become a little
country they were having to borrow money
from us to get food after the Second
World War the greatest nation on earth
for 200 years he hated that but you
thought the choice was because if when
he gets to the end and you can only make
decisions like this one there's no
alternative this is what Churchill
teaches
or their two final points the first one
is if you get to the place where you're
gonna surrender your power to resist to
the worst man in history better to die
there are Frenchmen who have ancestors
who sign orders to round up Jews because
otherwise their families would be shot
better to die that's the first lesson
you don't make extreme judgments except
in extreme circumstances and then pray
for the strength to make them but the
second was do you know what this proved
to Churchill it's the greatest thing of
all it's what he lived his life to prove
his whole life he could saved it he
thought these things are getting so big
war and production and nations and
science that people don't matter anymore
and sure enough the doctrine of Hitler
and the doctrine of Stalin is precisely
that people don't matter anymore it's
history it's the tides it's the great
movements throw up your hands you have
to be on the side of history to quote a
recent president you see or else
everything is vain but in the First
World War he writes this he says that in
the first one of course he tried to
avoid the trenches in the first world or
although he later fought in them well
and he devised a plan to get around them
and it was the Dardanelles and it didn't
work and it was a disgrace right and so
of course to justify it he rides a
six-volume book one of the greatest
books ever written my opinion certain
modern books and he says in there he
says that this year the 1915 the war
started in August 1914 in 1915
excuse me I have a phone call make the
bad man stop it's some friend of Bob
Norton's from Sacramento California I'll
betcha so he says sorry where was I was
I talking about something he says this
moment right here this incredible
congregation could have been stopped we
could have gotten control of it and then
he says a very interesting thing the
paragraph begins all this although this
account pretends to deal with the vast
theme it will follow I conceived on the
pathway that footsteps are decisive he
says these should be studied and
pondered over along these pathways where
the footsteps are decisive huge things
can happen and they don't matter but
along this disk chain he says of
commanding causation who knows when they
might set a stone rolling or take or
admit some it's some seemingly
unimportant step that changes everything
now that's an interesting thing right
because setting a stone rolling or
taking or omitting some scene seemingly
unimportant step that's like chance but
he's talking about choice
what do chance and choice have to do
with each other are they opposites are
the same in another place he says in
Mass Effect's in modern life he says he
says you know your own life is dominated
by accidents you know I met my wife
because I got on with Martin Gilbert and
because she was planning to leave Oxford
and go work in London but she got ill
and she couldn't go I wouldn't know her
but for that
you see it's extremely consequential
thing to us and our children but what if
it was Napoleon Churchill says what if
it was Churchill because that has
consequences for millions that means you
see that the stuff we do is significant
and he says along these pathways that's
where you can see quote the profound
significance of human choice and the
sublime responsibility of men and
Churchill was searching for that all his
life and that means on the 28th of May
when he walked in that room he was the
only one who could have done that he
thought God put him there
[Applause]
thank you
I'll stop being emotional now I'm done
with all that you guys are a bunch of
dunderheads
Dominic Whelan has a question oh yeah
Sidney Maron has a question
get ready Dominic remember I'm married
to Martin Gilbert's younger brother
that's right yes have you seen you never
met Martin Gilbert stand up Peter Peter
looks just like him you mentioned to me
once wonder your favourite photos of
Winston Churchill was after the Boer War
yeah when he was captured and there was
a group of officers and he was one of
them and all of the officers were their
heads were down in defeat because they
were captured but he was dealing with us
to define like a Bulldog's Justine and
looking straight in the camera that was
one of your favorite photos of so if you
could expound on that please yeah thank
you so it's a it actually wasn't defiant
he was contemptuous yeah so he fights in
this action around this armored train it
goes on for a long time there's a lot of
deaths and then he gets captured and and
you know they come riding up on horses
to get him he thought it was Louis Botha
later his friend and the president of
South Africa and it wasn't but he never
accepted that he could have been
captured by anybody except the future
path president of South Africa and he
reaches down and he's gonna shoot him
and he'd taken his gun off to work on
the Train so he's just really frustrated
and he's captured and so they March them
in the rain for hours and then they get
to another rail head and they put him on
a train and he rides on the train for
hours and they're pointing guns at him
and he converses with them and charms
them and finds out all about
where they're being taken and he arrives
with a plan to present to the commander
to take the officer's quarters
seize the weapons march to the stadium
where the enlisted men are liberate them
take the capital and in the war so it's
really great and along the way he wrote
a 1000 word article of which we have a
copy today in that crazy right and so so
he gets off the train in this train and
you know he's been a long time now right
and this train pulls into the middle of
Pretoria the capital of South Africa and
there's about 20 guys and they're lined
up and all about one of them or they're
lined up in ranks and all all but one of
them is looking like this they got their
heads down one guys looking like this
I've always wanted to know his name you
know what it is Richard we need to get
that picture and look that guy up I bet
there's a way to find out we should go
to South Africa and ask anyway
anyway Churchill is off to the side and
remember he's not a soldier he's in the
uniform looking thing but not like the
rest of them and here Pretoria staring
at them and they all look the shuffle
except him and he's standing
looking down his nose sideways that
right and I thought I wrote this one
time if Hitler had seen that picture he
might not have turned his back away from
Winston Churchill to go to sack Russia
because that could be a bad mistake yeah
so hey I like that picture thank you
I'll take a chance on asking a question
of perhaps making your remark had
Churchill been heated in the 30s and had
been able to stiffen the resolve of the
French and the British and they had
resisted Nazi expansion there was
considerable opportunity for the German
General Staff to have intervened and
perhaps opposed Hitler
so had Churchill been listened to in 33
34 35 and 36 isn't it a vast irony that
his role in history might likely have
been much smaller in terms of our
recognizing it even though his
contribution might have been greater in
terms of lives saved and that all seems
true to me I mean it's what he thought
and of course it's a hypothetical and
you never quite know but what he thought
was that the First World War was harder
to prevent although I worked at it
because nobody had really seen it and
the Germans in the First World War they
were not like Hitler what they were
really was a bunch of irresponsible rich
kids who inherited a bunch of stuff and
didn't know how to protect it but Hitler
was a very wicked thing and you could
see that if you looked and then Germany
is very weak when all this starts and so
it's just a matter of opposing them and
they'll stop they have to they don't
have anything in any way that guy's kind
of crazy and he and a lot of people
don't like him over there
so Churchill always called it the
unnecessary war the war what should we
call this war Prime Minister now
greatest man in the world and he said
that's easy this is the unnecessary war
he called it that many times he wrote it
many times you see so I think that the
stupidity and blindness of us is what
made that because we knew better by the
end or should've and and see it's hard
though because Churchill himself like we
fight in Iraq now and a lot of people
you know when you go fight in Iraq
anywhere you go fight anywhere in
America today you always quote Winston
Churchill and so on the one hand this
lesson from Hitler that's a lesson to
learn but it's just like every principle
it applies in the circumstances if you
get it right and never in exactly the
same way so I had somebody important in
the White House say to me one time do
you believe in freedom in Iraq and I
said yeah he said but I said well that
would be difficult wouldn't it and he
said why they want it and I said do they
but anyway I said is that what you think
it tanks and he said what does it take
and I said read the first 50 pages of
the Federalist Papers you know takes a
lot of things and he said Winston
Churchill founded Iraq and I said you
know you always know just enough to be
dangerous I said you know he his he was
a head of the colonial office he had
fought for two years a battle a year and
a half in the British government to keep
written from taking territory from the
former Ottoman Empire he didn't want it
didn't think they needed it doesn't be
nothing but trouble and so then he and
TE Lawrence his number two they decided
to get out of Iraq the minute that they
could and so what that means is
the the principle is be prepared and the
principle is don't go involving yourself
and stuff but you don't need to and so
which applies come to find out we have
to live our own lives alas and we'll do
better says Aristotle if we study the
people who really are good at making the
great decisions but you do have to study
them carefully because there's a hundred
places I can name where Winston
Churchill did not want to get involved
but I think you're right about that that
he won his glory through something he
tried to prevent thank you
[Applause]
you